you know who had no problem with the
setup the guy who's in charge of the
USGA Mike Davis loved it it was all good
in his hood I'm sure rich Lerner of the
golf channel joining us right now from
Shinnecock how are you rich I'm doing
really well rich yeah they have the US
Open that's a they want US Open they
used to deliver you know the one where
they we constantly say it's a thorough
examination if you're going to as if
you're going to dr. hurts a lot so where
you're you you know you're going to
wince you know you're going to be
relieved when it's over and you you damn
well know that you do not want to come
back for another five years
that's the thorough examination of the
US Open well I mean to you I guess
continue with the Fletch analogy than
rich it seems like they're using the
whole fist here though is the problem
you know for some of these players and
to me is the is it have to be one way or
the other like extreme in either
direction he's in there a gray area to
try and set up the course or is this the
way that we should expect it from the US
Open rich I think it'll depend on the
golf course
yesterday was sort of a confluence of
the brutal factors you had a firm turf
and then you had cross winds gusting up
to 30 miles per hour week in week out on
the PGA Tour these guys can sort of
launch the ball high and know that it's
going to come down softly and they can
control their golf ball you see the ball
is rolling off and it's happened to
Tiger a lot in fact the triple bogey he
made at number one yesterday that was
exactly where he was ball rolls down
he's got like 15 20 yards
you could either chip it where you could
put it he did both and it came back down
to his feet so it's just difficult does
it have to be super hard no they could
set it up easily but I think what they
want is to challenge players in ways
that we can week out they are not and
and then it's beyond the sort of
technical side of the game they want to
find out who can persevere who commits
the shots whose patient who hangs in
who's top who's got guts and it's a
climb up Everest
this isn't a stroll along the beach in
you know in Cabo San Lucas which it
typically is week to week this is
something altogether different
that said though rich Lerner in the
Honda insider report it sure looks like
Dustin Johnson seven a day at the beach
he just rolled in while we were
conversing a forty five foot five inch
pot well for birdie you know and he's
4-under right now what Richard this is
this is you know this is almost unfair
at this point I mean you go back to
kapalua January first tournament of the
new year he hit one of the greatest
drives in the history of golf four
hundred and forty yard par-4 little bit
downhill and he almost made an ace we
know that this guy can pound it forever
but now he he's added touch to his game
so this would be the equivalent of your
Blake Griffin you 360 windmill dunks
spectacular freak athlete and now you
add Steph Curry's touch so he's right
now he's sort of Kevin Durant fish he's
kind of unstoppable hits it you know
beautifully cheetah green but he's
scrambling so well and that that's bad
news for the rest of the field because
this guy though I think he's interesting
and he think back to his major
championship through history
he had bunker gate in Wisconsin and one
epen think you remember that yep and
then he shot an 82 at Pebble Beach in
the final round and then he had you know
to iron out of bound British Open and a
few years after that and he looked to be
you remember the movie Bull Durham he
looked like nuke LaLoosh
million dollar arm with a five cent head
that was kind of the book on Gustin
which was sort of unfair turns out he
actually has a really good sort of brain
for the game in that he
he lets mistakes roll off his back and
he moves on and now he's added this sort
of short game prowess which he hadn't
had to go with his ridiculous length and
it competes he's 33 years old to be 30
or in a week and a half I think and he's
on the verge of two majors and 19 career
wins that's just you know that's Ernie
Ellis territory this is a guy who's
probably going to end up when all is
said and done with
you know maybe 30 wins and four or five
majors he'll be one of the 20 best
players of all time if he doesn't get
hurt and if he you know if he stays
focused and it looks like right now rich
Lerner the golf channel hunt inside a
report looks like he has the opportunity
to run away and hide right now I mean I
I agree yeah I mean that this is this a
day where he can put some separation
now it's 75 out there it is
and you know we saw a few years ago we
were handing it to him at st. Andrews
had to give us 2015 and he played a
terrible round on Saturday so on this
golf course anything is possible but
you're buying itself margin for error
and error is coming even for a guy like
Dustin so that's important rich Lerner
the golf channel here on the Rich Eisen
show what do you think the cut line is
going to be you know it looks like
double digits probably and you know
Tiger very likely won't make it I mean
you know he is what he is right now rich
he's the 80th ranked player in the world
that's kind of what he is no better
could he could he get better yes will he
win again I would say likely yes is he
going to catch Nicklaus no and you know
he just doesn't drive it yes he doesn't
drive it well enough and there must be
some sort of like performance anxiety
which you know sounds bizarre given
we're talking about the greatest
performer likely in the history of the
sport that was a long time ago because
you know he's hitting the ball by all
accounts perfectly in his warmups but
it's a long walk from the range the
first tee and he doesn't have the magic
in his putter he doesn't have the juice
in his putter that he used to have this
doesn't make anything he used to make
everything so you know the grind is
still there the attitude seems good but
it's you know he's almost 43 years old
and so he's running out of he's running
out of time ask him the poll question
Chris Brockman asked rich Lerner the
poll question here rich which one of
these guys is most likely to make the
cut looking at Phil
in Jason Day rory mcilroy I'd say still
no word came and I I mean I don't
understand Rory I really I just don't I
was in London for the BMW PGA
Championship the European Tour and he
said 67-65 Thursday Friday Alex Noren
who's the top 20 in the world played
alongside he came off the court said
I've never seen anything that good in my
life I should quit he has the ability to
blow your mind
but he just there's just something right
now missing and then I say that and
he'll do what he did at Bay Hill Sunday
64 but McIlroy is it the clock is
ticking in some ways for Rory if he had
four majors at 25 he was headed for
all-time bill you know he Nicholas said
he would win 15 majors back in 2014 so
he's now close to four years without a
major and he's 29 years old the window
is shorter than people think so you know
I'm a little perplexed by Rory and I
think Jordan this is like the first
really rough patch of his career he's in
a funk I don't think there's any doubt
about that will he get out of it I no
doubt in my mind he's too good and he's
too good an athlete he thinks he thinks
too well
so he'll he will come out of it I just
don't know when but in arguably he's in
a funk right now rich thanks for the
call appreciate it enjoy the rest of the
weekend out there in the Hamptons enjoy
thanks rich you gotta that's rich Lerner
GC the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience